[Music]  tonight before we continue I thought  would take just a minute to check in  with Andy Richter see what stories he's  working on for next week Andy thank you  :  coming up next week our prizes in cereal  boxes getting worse and should the  elderly be used as paper weights one  company says yes plus a story business  people won't want you to miss is your  seashell giving you bad advice put your  balls on the table and our mannequins  moving into your neighborhood what you  can do about it  and an in-depth look at that new guy in  your office what exactly does he do  and my new report on workplace bullying  ass why is it so much fun I bet your  parents are really proud of ya and  finally we'll meet a pope who isn't  Catholic and a bear that doesn't in the  woods  [Applause]